Uh, just to make sure you're in the right place, uh,
we're gonna be talking Apache Iceberg,
and we're gonna walk through what Warner Music
Group has been doing with it.
I will kick us off. Uh, my
name's William Rashon. I'm the
industry principal for the media and entertainment
category at Snowflake.
Um, I have
Michael Jones with me, uh, who's gonna
share a case study and deep dive
on
how they're using Iceberg and the
impacts it's having at the business.
Uh, before we do that, I
will give a little background on Iceberg.
Um, I'm assuming a lot of people because
you've came here have some familiarity with it.
Uh, but, uh, we'll do a quick
backgrounder on what Iceberg is,
where it came from,
and then some, uh, best practices
that we see in the, uh,
media industry and how customers
are leveraging it,
and, uh, we'll share, you know, some
statistics on, uh, kind of the
pace of innovation that we've seen on it as well.
Uh, so with that, uh, just to level
set on what is Iceberg,
uh, where does it fit into the picture,
uh, in a technology landscape,
uh, so it's a data lake
table format,
uh, it's a layer of abstraction
for various query engines that,
uh, clients might be using.
Uh, the things that we hear
from customers and what we see is that,
you know, really enables them to,
uh, open up their data,
uh, wherever it sits, uh, to be
able to have a consistent way to access all of
that, uh, so you get
a lot of the benefits that you might see from
using a data platform. Like Snowflake when
it comes to governance, performance,
uh, ease of management,
uh, and you have that unified layer
across all the data sources,
um, when it comes to, uh, a
format like Iceberg, uh, what
we see is that, you know what you're looking
for is consistency,
uh, you're looking for the ability to,
uh, have all the teams access the
same data
and have the ability to go back in
time and review the data and how it's changed
as well.
Uh, so the, the big features that we see,
you know, what are the things that, uh, clients
are getting out of Iceberg and why are they using
it, uh, so it's the partition
evolution, it's, uh, the hidden
partitioning, uh, asset compliance,
time travel, and then, uh, flexibility
are kind of the, the core, uh,
features that a lot of our clients get value
out of when it comes to Apache Iceberg.
Um,
we've heard, uh, a lot of feedback from
customers too that, you know, they, they really
wanna have as much control as
possible. They don't wanna be,
um,
only using a single platform. I think in
companies like Warner Music and other big media
companies it's just not realistic to only
have one
system to store all of your data
given, you know, acquisitions and. Mergers
and uh changes that are happening
all the time in the industry
uh so this gives them uh an
open design framework so they could work with
that data uh wherever it sits
uh we kind of view it as a
composability is a word that we use a lot
where
uh you're kind of bringing in best of
breed from whatever tools make sense
for the data that you might be leveraging.
Uh, the ecosystem is a
big part of Iceberg as well, so you, you know,
as leveraging that, uh,
uh, format and that type, you're gonna get
access to a broader
network and system of tools
and data sources that, uh, become
accessible, uh, through the platform.
And then finally efficiency so,
uh, when it comes to Iceberg, one of the
big benefits is you don't have to have
multiple copies of your data.
Uh, you can make sure everyone's, uh,
accessing data consistently
and, uh, from the same place,
um. What we've seen,
uh, very recently, I was just looking at some of the,
uh, metrics on the media and entertainment
side just within, uh, Snowflake,
uh, we're seeing a ton of momentum, uh,
so just looking over the last quarter
we saw a 300%
increase in.
The number of queries that are being done
uh using Iceberg and the data that's sitting
within it,
um, and the 400%
increase in the, uh,
create process within those tables as well,
so, uh, massive adoption,
massive usage, and continued
growth is what we're seeing as well.
Um,
and this is, you know, a lot of reasons why
I think we're seeing a, uh, the
gravitation towards Iceberg is the
table format of choice.
Uh, the project has a lot of, uh,
supporters, uh, definitely not just snowflakes,
so AWS is, uh, definitely behind
it as well,
uh, and that rapid growth continues and
you get access to all of the
support behind that. Uh,
just looking at the momentum from
GitHub around the project,
uh, this is just a, you know, kind of timeline
on, uh, the active contributors
over the, uh, past couple
of years.
Uh, you could see Iceberg has
grown and continues. Take off,
uh, it's moving faster than other formats
like Delta Lake, um, and
some of the big contributors to the project are
Netflix,
Apple and Amazon,
uh, they tend to be always at the top in terms
of contributions for the project, so,
uh, you're in very good company.
Uh, what is,
how does this fit into the overall,
uh,
systems that customers are using?
Uh, so the lake house architecture is
one that we see,
uh, fairly widely adopted across
our customer base at this point,
and there's really these three layers,
uh, that are within that architecture.
So there's a compute layer, there's the catalog
layer, and the storage layer,
um,
and, uh.
The ability to have separation between
these and to understand how they operate
is what we'll talk through very quickly here as
well. Um, the storage layer
is really the foundation, so this
is sort of the, the place where
all of the data can come together,
uh, you get that benefit
of having the compatibility
across these different systems, uh, when you're taking
an iceberg approach with this,
um, and it's really gonna, uh,
kind of set you up for the, uh,
ability to collaborate across your teams
across the different entities that might be within your
organization. The
catalog layer becomes that source of
truth, so this is where
um the teams are able to have those
consistent views of the data sets
uh across teams uh this
becomes a place where
um
that common language comes
into place uh it has the
uh transactional rigor around it
that I think a lot of enterprise customers are looking
for as well.
Uh, and then finally the compute layer, and
this is really where all the work gets done. So
this is where, uh, you're gonna be
interacting and querying and
processing the data at the top layer,
uh, and this is,
you know, by having this foundation, this is
really what's gonna set you up to be able to execute
a lot of the innovative things that are happening
around, uh, AI and analytics
that we're seeing in the space right now.
Uh, these are,
uh, general recommendations
that we see around, uh, approaching,
uh, a lake house analytics approach.
Um, the first one would be
access, uh, and this is where.
You know, as an enterprise asking yourself,
uh, can you securely unify
all the data that your team needs wherever
it might sit,
uh, the second would be performance
and understanding the
requirements around concurrency and
speed,
uh, when it comes to all the data
customers that you're working with
and then finally empowerment. So are you
giving. The teams that you're working
with, uh, production ready data
to be able to build the products that they wanna build,
and that's an area where we've definitely seen the
pace of change, uh,
really pick up over the last couple of years,
the ability to,
you know, deliver code faster deliver data
faster,
uh, and the demands that all of our clients
continue to increase there so that's definitely an important
one. Uh, and then
finally this is, this is sort of
where things end up from a, a very high
level architecture perspective and
um what we wanna be able to do is,
you know, support the enterprise customers
that we work with, uh, make sure that
the entire business
is connected, uh, you have that
ecosystem of data sets that you're
working with, uh,
you have the ability to partner
with, uh, all of your customers
and external.
Uh, partners but also internal teams,
uh, to eliminate some of the
complexities that used to be there around having
copies of data and ETL
processes,
um, it really becomes simplified
when you take, uh, an iceberg approach,
uh, to your data lake house,
uh, and then finally.
Uh, just thinking about, you know, what are
the benefits when you get there, so
what happens as an end state,
uh, you're gonna have better query
performance, you're gonna have cost optimizations,
you have better data integration,
uh, scalability, and then finally,
um, you can do all of this in a cross
cloud environment
and, uh, with that
I will turn it over and, uh,
Michael's gonna take you through, uh,
exactly how this comes to life for Warner Music.
Yeah, thank you, um,
yeah, hey, it is, I guess I should click
ahead there we go, uh, when the iceberg Saves
you is what I entitled this, um,
maybe a little dramatic but not so much at
a complex organization like Warner,
um, so just a little bit about me, um,
uh, my name is Mike Jones, you call me Mike or Michael.
I am the director for data
engineering, so I own
basically all of our, uh, ETL
and pipelines at Warner Music Group,
um, and it's a very complicated
environment with. A lot of history and you're probably
here because you probably have a complicated environment
too and need iceberg in your life.
So what I would say about that is that um
this is this is just sort of an
opportunity for us to share
a little bit of about of our our experience
um working under a lot of constraints,
uh, some things we can't control, some things we can't control,
and being able to actually, um, you
know, uh, really create a seamless
data environment with a very complex system.
So I'll jump into that,
um. This is the agenda
we'll be going over. I'll, I'll tell you a little bit about WMG.
Maybe you already know about Warner Music. I'll go over the
challenges and just how we built
an architecture of interoperability,
um, and it's, that's not just marketing. We actually
have this, this working which is really cool,
um, with Iceberg as the, I don't know, connective
tissue is what we called it.
Uh, and I'll share some learnings and outcomes, uh, with
you after that.
So, um, Warner Music Group, uh,
Warner represents 75 years
of music history, so it's, it's a
pretty cool place.
It's pretty cool history.
I mean, you probably see artists up there that you
recognize, um, it's a really,
really exciting place to be,
and, um.
And you know it's kind of funny because it's the first
place where, where my kids were like, uh, Dad,
you have a cool job.
Like I, I worked in like AWS and drones
and stuff. No, no, no, this is cool.
I, you know, when you're 10 this music is cool, right?
And it is, it's, it's really cool and fascinating and
complicated business and so
we, we actually,
um, it, it houses.
Numerous labels and sub labels
and um what that means is that we have a
very
complex distributed decentralized
environment
um that doesn't have standardization in
a lot of areas and uh
that creates a lot of challenges for data
and also means that we're in a multi-engine
multi-platform environment
um and so
what I wanted to say too at the outset here is that
like. Uh, you know, being an
AWS alumni, if you looked at my LinkedIn
several years ago,
I'll appeal to like my favorite leadership principle
which is learn and be curious.
If you're gonna do anything with this stuff in an interoperable
environment, you need a lot of curiosity, and
curiosity is kind of the lifeblood of an
organization that can actually achieve great things.
And I think we've done some really, really cool stuff with
Snowflake and Iceberg and AWS
and other platform engines like Data bricks,
uh, over the, over the last couple of years.
And so I'll, I'll get into a bunch of that.
Um,
so I, I talked a little bit about this
before, but it, it's important to like
note that um
WMG tech is a centralized
corporate function
that sits underneath all of these decentralized
labels,
and that is really
challenging because those labels can make a. A lot of
autonomous decisions and have
for years
that have created a lot of history that we
can't just snap our fingers and change
and so what that means is even if we want to introduce
new technologies and practices and tools,
uh, new engines or teams want to use different
engines, all this stuff is still there
and it's evolving too
and so this is the kind of like context
in which we have to kind of like
challenge this is the challenge that we have with this stuff.
So in particular
we have all of our because we're
a multi-engine multi-vendor environment
and so all of our classic
lake house
and our BI,
our analysts, like our recorded music analysts,
marketing,
all of them are on Snowflake, so we have
like hundreds of pipelines, I think 600 pipelines
in Snowflake that are running.
Uh, from raw ingest all the way up through to gold
layer,
and our analysts and RM analysts
are BI. They prefer Snowflake as their tool
of choice. And
on the other hand, we have like a, a sizable
portion of infrastructure on data bricks
where, where our new data mesh is built.
So you can imagine we have like data bricks over here with a data
mesh, and then we've got like our classic lake house
medallion architecture over here with BI and RM.
And they need things from each other
and so that's where where we started to
really explore and get on this journey of learning
to figure out like hey like how can we
make all this work together.
Um, and so that's
the real question, like how do we take like
huge volumes of data and
um and be able to access
it across multiple
engines for a huge distributed
diverse decentralized group that
they don't really want standards all the
time and so you can't just make them do
it a certain way either.
So this, this is how the environment
that we're in and it, it poses a lot of challenge and
if we do it right,
uh, then we support our artists, our songwriters
better we can help them make better decisions with the data
and uh music thrives is
basically how it works.
So um so it's really exciting, a lot of
crazy challenging problems for us to deal with, um,
but that's that's why we're here and that's what's fun about it
so. I wanted to jump into just a
few of the use cases that
I've got that we have just to give you a flavor
of it. So
one of them is
we just launched WMG Pulse
and what that is is it's an artist and
songwriter facing app that serves
up analytical insights and financial transparency.
So it's a pretty cool,
pretty cool app.
That thing actually sits on top of.
Data products and the data mesh that themselves
are using data from Snowflake that's raw ingested
and transformed under Snowflake. So that's one challenge. So
how do you do that? Like, do we manually
copy data around? Do you like use
federated queries every everywhere? Do we reverse
ETL it? These are like the challenges that we
hit. Second example I mentioned our
BI, our marketing, our recorded music and analysts.
They're using
like Snowflake,
uh, they're, they're, they're
the entire BI. An analyst community
is is heavily built onto Snowflake. They use Tableau.
They use a lot of direct queries.
They have a lot of
what we call homebrew ETL that they've built on
top of the fundamental data pipelines.
That stuff is all on Snowflake,
and it has millions, actually, sorry, so it's like
billions of queries a month,
and it also now needs data from
the data mesh too, as well as other sources.
I'm talking about that, but we've got stuff in Legacy, Postgress,
Oracle, all over the place.
Um,
then we have our ML team. They prefer to use ML
flow, uh, so that's sitting in data bricks, but
they're working on a lot of data in Snowflake, and
we actually do do some,
we do do AI and ML on Snowflake as well.
So there's this back and forth of data
across both there again.
And then
there's 3rd party integrations where we literally need to
share hundreds of terabytes of constantly
evolving data with third parties
and and receive data from those third parties.
So like a good example would be like Spotify
sends us streaming data, so we get billions
of rows a day
from these streaming things because you all like
to listen to music and so we get lots
of streams coming in all the time.
And so that stuff comes in through Snowflake
and then has to go out to all these other systems.
So we have a lot of challenges.
Um, and I wanted to
start with like the goal of
what we're trying to do, OK?
So I'll, I'll put this image up in front of
you right now,
because I'll come back to it, but I wanted to show you
this, this.
This kind of vision of it, so you'll notice in the middle there,
it's not too small for you,
that we have this unified iceberg
data layer,
OK, and then on the right you've got the engine,
so you'll see you've got Snowflake there,
data bricks, there's all these legacy analytical
tools, there's a bunch of third party stuff flying
around in there.
And on the other side there's sources, this could be like
Spotify, DSPs, that type of thing like
we get.
And so this is the goal. This is the goal is that we somehow
live in this beautiful harmony
where we get tons of data from all these eclectic
sources.
It's just magically all in the right place, and
then all of these things with all their differences can
just use that data magically, right? And
Right, it's not quite magical and it didn't get there
magically, but it's not that far off now, which
is kind of cool.
So what I wanted to jump in is
use and show you is just use one
example as kind of a case study
for this.
This isn't the only example we've got, and we're doing a lot
of other stuff, but this one was
fairly easy. It doesn't have much proprietary
concerns, so it's really easy for me to talk about,
um. So,
I wanted to share about WMG Opus
on Iceberg. Now Opus is
an internal tool
um that's used by, I think it's about 700
users at Warner Music, so it's our most
used tool.
And it essentially
is a tool for viewing like streams,
social data, charts, playlists. You can
go there and look at how
an artist is, is doing on all of
these metrics internally, and it's also
externally facing. We actually have
external users who connect to this thing.
And so
this, this
tool is, um,
it exists as sort of a, it's
a React app, well React
website that sits on top of a legacy
Java Spring
backend called DVAPI.
And that Legacy JavaSpring backend actually
does a lot of direct reads of Snowflake.
So just for the streaming data
alone, and by that I mean like you're listening to music,
there's 15 APIs with all of their sub-routes
that themselves call dozens of different tables
in Snowflake directly.
So you're like, why are you crying? Snowflake directly, that's a really
good question. Operational thing querying analytical
space, not maybe the best way to do it, but that's what's
there, and it's built that way, and it can
take 20 seconds to query
at times, which is not the best,
but it's there, and these are the kind of constraints
that we operate under because this is the most used
tool that we have.
And so
one of the challenges that we hit right away
was that Opus actually needed to
use a net new,
a new streaming
product in our data bricks data mesh.
So now you can imagine this stack here
in Opus, and I wonder if I have it on the next slide.
Yes, I do. Here we go.
So
this one here, if you look at this, we've got
Opus sitting there
on top of what's called our DV data visualization
API.
So this is a legacy API, the JavaSpring thing
I was talking about,
and we, it's reading from
snowflake gold, snowflake silver, bronze, which is all
processed through there. There's, there's a lot of pipelines
that are going in. This is hundreds of terabytes of data
that's processed through here. And aggregated
and transformed and re-transformed and re-aggregated
and and eventually served up to be
like, hey, you know what your track is outperforming
in country X
so this here is the
the just the high level architecture
and we needed to actually get data
from data bricks
into DV API.
And so it's like, well, what are, what are kind of the
options we have here?
Well, um,
we could migrate DVAPI to data bricks, but
that would be just
prohibitive for one thing.
There's tons of other APIs that run on
it. Uh, there's a lot of other snowflake stuff
that's gonna live there
forever. We're not gonna, we don't wanna change that
stuff. We don't actually have
that big an engineering team on Opus
and DB API anymore. It's actually largely
pretty small. It's in like. KTLO mode,
but it's still heavily used by the business so
again you've got to work within the constraints that you've got.
The other problem is is that it's, it's
extremely disruptive to go and change this
API out from under the hood, like
to re-engineer it. It's a huge effort,
um, and again, as I said,
the BI and analysts prefer Snowflake, so
what that means is they're actually reading the tables
directly themselves
and looking at them and getting information from them, and that's
where they want to do it.
So we can't just go like
pull the rug out and just be like, OK, let's put this over
on a different engine, that won't work.
And like I said, there's stuff that are not on that
engine, we actually need it from both.
The second option is what, what
I kind of threw up here is like legacy delta integration.
This was,
I, I like to joke half my production stack is on
private previews, but we're actually looking at like DLT
private previews with Snowflake on like being able
to just direct read Delta.
Uh, it doesn't, didn't work very well and it's since evolved
into a much better system, but this was
back in 2023. It's, it's not really
a great option,
but um. We're, we're looking at this,
and then the third one was uniform iceberg.
Now if you know uniform, that's like
Databer's Unity catalog Iceberg can
export. So into Iceberg they can just
take delta,
a delta table which is parquet,
and you just wrap a delta log metadata around it
and then loop, and
lo and behold, if you go drop that thing into S3,
Snowflake
catalog can go and point at it and read
it. Through the rest API, so
that's pretty cool.
So this was like hmm, we're like maybe that'll work.
So we,
that's what we did we set this up, the,
the, we set it up so that
we would actually
um take the streaming data from
this data product.
And using the original, the same snowflake
tables
that the API is reading from.
We would actually just point those tables
at essentially using the rest as the
API to S3.
We just point them at the iceberg tables
and produce them there,
which meant, and I think this is what's really cool and
probably one of the biggest changes over the years,
we could bring Snowflake to the data,
which is really, really cool, right? Like we didn't
have to bring the data in, we could bring snowflake to the data,
which I think was really an awesome thing that we were able
to start doing, and this was just the start of it, so.
What we saw with this, and this is really the
key insight,
was to make our entire
data layer
platform and engine agnostic.
This is like the big idea that kind of clicked
at a moment, like, wait a minute, why don't we.
Why don't we just actually make it agnostic
so that I can point
Snowflake at anything I want and Snowflake can produce
whatever I want in Iceberg and vice versa
with other engines like data bricks,
and that way I don't actually have to choose. I can get the
best of both worlds simultaneously
and actually we have, we have a lot more
optionality and strengths, and you can leverage
the innovations that are coming out of multiple
platforms at the same time, which is really
interesting. So we
had our initial success with Iceberg,
um, and
a little interesting,
um, there's supposed to be a diagram there, but I'm
not sure where it went.
Maybe it's the next slide. Oh yeah, there we go. OK, cool, not
sure why I did that.
OK, so we had our initial success with Iceberg,
and this is where sort of our, our
first application of snowflake.
It was running a billion queries
per month. It's running a billion queries a month
through those snowflake tables
into Iceberg.
Um, and so that was half the half the battle
to start. The second half is how do
we get the data products to read data from Snowflake.
I haven't talked about this yet, but ironically
the data mesh actually is reading tons of bronze
and silver data from Snowflake.
So they, so initially they start, the
team started out doing this with federated query.
And if you don't know what a federated query is, basically
what it is, is, is from, from
say Data Brook's perspective, what they're gonna do
is you're gonna fire up a cluster, it's gonna dispatch
a query over to Snowflake. That cluster is gonna sit there
waiting.
Spending money, but it will sit there, and
Snowflake will actually run the query, and then the
answer comes back. So you actually have double compute
happening while your query's dispatched over
and then it comes back.
So this, this works, but it's,
it's kind of not great in some
ways because your EC2 usage just
skyrockets while it's handling all of this
metadata processing and everything else.
So, so this, this was what we had
set up initially
and, and
eventually what we did was,
especially through the innovations coming out of Snowflake, we
were actually able to flip this over to federate a catalog
with ice. Which
essentially meant
easy to
really down we didn't have to actually spend that
for all of the processing
um we didn't have to dispatch queries.
Data bricks could directly read the
tables published. Published is not
the technical word, but the tables that are available from
Snowflake
either through managed or external iceberg
in Snowflake, which is really cool,
so.
That brought us to this,
and this is the thing that is kind
of like,
wow, we actually went and did this, uh but uh
you remember the diagram I showed you on the left that was original
architecture.
If you look at the bottom there, you'll see we've got
that red box there,
and what's happening there is that that
um
that is essentially the data
product that lives in data bricks, and what it does is it
uses federated catalog
to read from the bronze silver layers in Snowflake.
And it actually makes the result
available back to Snowflake
via iceberg.
Uh, essentially what I said you can
publish delta tables as
um because they're so similar you can
publish them essentially as Iceberg and Snowflake can just
pick them right up
and then they're available and what was really cool
is that this actually worked and it worked really
well like we only saw a performance
drop of about 10% in terms of query
performance
from the application and that didn't even matter
because the hit was absorbed by
the parallelization within the app actually
the Opus actually running.
So what this meant was we were actually
able to interleaave
different engines together
pretty much seamlessly with zero copies
um in a performance application,
and we did it
without any of the business users noticing. So we just
did this under the hood,
we told them it was happening just in case something went wrong, but,
but they didn't,
they didn't notice. They were like, we didn't notice a difference.
We're like,
yes, that doesn't always happen for us,
believe me, but it happened this time, so,
so I see some guys laughing.
Uh, but yes, it doesn't always happen, but it did work this
time. So this actually worked, and this was
like something that would have been like we couldn't have even
imagined
a few years ago in terms of the level
of interoperability that we could achieve.
And so this, this actually ends
up like
opening up the doors for us. Like, so
what we did was we, we expanded our success
by sort of expanding our iceberg usage. So this
is just another example where
like why use a REST API on
S3 when Snowflake has what's called native iceberg.
Um, I don't know if that's what you're still calling it, but essentially
like Snowflake can actually manage
the table. I think it's managed iceberg can manage the
table for you,
and so you don't actually need it, it actually
appears as like a snowflake native table,
um, but it's available for external readers if
you want to read it. There's some constraints like
they can't write to it naturally, but, but that's
perfect for us. We just want to make data available,
um, but this is really, really cool because
now we can use this to share data
with third parties.
And actually other parts of our business
as well as we can get other vendors
and partners to give data to us like this.
Which means we don't have to spend a ton of compute
processing ingestion of rows and stuff.
We just take an iceberg table, Snowflake can wrap
it up
one way or the other, whether managed or external,
and we can make it available and then we can seamlessly
weave our engines together,
which opens up a lot of doors for machine
learning and AI where they have to go and grab
sources from all kinds of
wild places in our business.
So this is what's really kind of an exciting thing for
us. And this lands us on this
what I call unified interrup between
data platforms. So
on the, the, so I've got a kind of like
space you can kind of see the different options there
like how do you read from Snowflake? Well, a
snowflake manage table is really great for that.
So that's what we're doing. We're creating these snowflake managed
tables,
and there's so much work happening on this front on. Snowflake, this
is getting better like by the month almost, which
is awesome,
um, getting more seamless, more efficient,
uh, uh, almost monthly,
and so it's really, really cool what's happening, but we're actually
able to then
make this data to any data, any
of our data,
which is about 3.2 petabytes
in snowflake, and we've got about 4 petabytes in
data bricks.
Um,
and so between the, it's about 50/50
between that amount of data
that's in these 22 spaces
we're able to make any of that data available
for any side of it. So that means we don't
have to actually rewrite engines, we can just bring the
engine to the data,
which is really, really slick for us
for reading into Snowflake.
Same thing, you just, we could use an externally
managed table,
which is what I described earlier with Opus, and
this data just flows right in and
and we're able to do it.
Um, so
this, there's, there's a number of edges to
this, of course, because,
uh, with anything like this, the, there's a bit of devil
in the details, which is why I mentioned curiosity
at the beginning.
Um, it doesn't always click
together perfectly. There's a lot of
like
little platform differences such as how they treat
metadata, how they update it between things
that can be challenging,
and uh, I'm a bit on that later, but
this is where like.
If you can kind of get over a bit of those what I
call just teething pains because it's like way better
than it was before,
you can actually get over those teething pains and then it
just works pretty seamlessly, and
those things are being
improved constantly, which is awesome.
So I just outlined there when
you want to use either like snowflake managed or
externally managed, you can go and dig up on
that. There's plenty of documentation on it,
but by putting those two
approaches together from a snowflake perspective,
you're actually able to get the full in and out
interoperation. story
in a format that is widely supported and
I mean you, you saw it on the graph,
but really like not a lot of engines are are
like reading Delta Lake natively for
example in in our environment so
like we just don't have that option even though a lot of our
data is in DLT right
um so iceberg is the way for us to go
and so.
What happens is is that iceberg becomes this
interoperability layer,
and it turns like our data mesh,
data bricks, and our classic data lake in Snowflake
into this like unified multi-platform
collaboration friendly system.
And it's not just marketing
speak, it actually works, and
they've had teething pains along the way, but it works
and it works really well, and
we're actually, it works so well for us we're actually
like even the engineers are visibly excited
about it at this point. They're just like,
wow, wait a minute, we could use iceberg over
here and it will simplify this, and we can use it over here and it'll
simplify this,
and now we're basically just constrained on our own ability
to convert these tables and make them
available and stuff, but once they are there. Um,
it becomes sort of a unified way where if someone
says I need this data, we're like icebergify
it. I don't know if that's a verb yet,
but icebergify it and, uh,
and it's there for you,
which is what we're doing, um, so just
this month, like hundreds of more terabytes
are being icebergified right now as I
speak, and it should be done. The job should be done today,
uh, but we're doing it literally more and more with
more data to make it available and make it more seamless,
um, which is really, really neat.
Um, so that means that
Snowflake for, for Snowflake
and any other engines, Iceberg becomes this
API between the systems.
That's the other way that I'd like to think about it. You've
got this
data layer that's agnostic of the
platform that you're on
or the engine you're on.
And you can store that data layer wherever you
want, um, and actually
all the engines typically because they, they're natively
supporting it, even if they own it
like a snowflake managed table, it's effectively
an engine agnostic representation
so it's really nice you don't actually have to move the data out you
can just like
you flip switches and suddenly it's available,
which is really, really cool.
So what this means is now
with Iceberg we are actually
processing like billions of queries
a month.
We have hundreds of terabytes with Iceberg
right now. We are,
we have started on this journey of integrating
vendors
with it, like external third party
vendors. We have to send a lot of data out
to third parties and we have to get a lot of
data from third parties
and we have.
Kinda,
kinda old legacy reverse ETL
systems, they work for doing that like
CDC,
that type of thing, but this is way better.
Like we want Iceberg to be actually the
API that if you were to go to Warner Music Group and
want an integration, we'd say,
oh yeah, Iceberg,
because it's actually kind of difficult for them if they,
if they don't have Snowflake, it's harder for them to connect
to our snowflake
and and that type of thing. So this makes it way,
way easier.
So
what this means is that like
we actually are able to like move
the data back and forth between platforms
and make it available
in this like triangle of third parties
to multiple engines and in the middle we've got
this this agnostic data layer
that you can read and write from
from any position and use for any use
case without
costs. Uh, without extra
copies,
without having to do translations,
and all the benefits you said before it's like asset
compliant, you get actually history if you
look at the architecture of how Iceberg is,
um, it's really cool because you're essentially
just updating like pointers to manifest
files. So as long as you haven't vacuumed up your
old data, you actually have time travel going
backward for Iceberg.
So it's really neat and Iceberg
V3 and V4 I think are coming out, so it's
like there's a lot more that's coming up too.
So I'll talk about a little bit about the
learnings and we're gonna open it up for some some
discussion, I think
um so here's a few, a few things. So this is some
of the the snowflake ones, uh, snowflake
learnings,
and then I've got a little bit on outcomes
so, so initially, and I think actually
almost all of these things are in progress right now
actually so, so that's. Shows you the rate of
change, but initially there was like no
fail-safe. Like you had to manage your own backups and versioning.
Um, I think the Lake House team is actually doing some pretty cool
stuff here now as well. Um,
right now presently there is a conversion
compute required if you migrate from standard
snowflake tables to iceberg.
It's like a one time unload and reload
of your data.
It can be pretty big if you're doing it for like
a large amount of data, but if you have a
large amount of data, it's relatively small compared
to what you're probably spending in compute anyway,
and then the benefit is quite worth it once it's done.
So, so this is a little different
because on on other engines like a, a,
a data bricks, um, because it's DLT and
it's in parquet already, they just wrap metadata
around it,
um, whereas Snowflake still has to do this conversion
thing right now, um, but that's, that's
in progress right now with them, which is really cool. I think
we're gonna, there's gonna be some really neat changes there.
Um, partition file sizes. So one of the
interesting things was that
for a, a snowflake external table,
the initial partition size was 16 megabytes,
which if you know anything about Iceberg, they recommend like 256
to 512.
And what that means is that let's say
you have a billion queries a month
and your partition sizes are 16 megabytes.
And you need to prune data for these queries.
If you might
do the, you know, AWS engineer math
in your head, you might be thinking, oh, wait a minute, that probably
means that you're gonna get a lot of API calls.
And you're right, you get a lot of API calls
with something like that happening.
So this initially hit us and like our, our
API usage just went
skyrocketed.
So that was really interesting learning. It's like, OK, and
then uh we worked with Snowflake and we got 128
megabyte partitions and
came right down.
So that was a really interesting learning there.
We were able to tune this partition size and and
make it much more efficient there,
um, and of course that would apply to an external
table. A Snowflake managed table would
handle it for you natively, which is really
cool. Um, this, the external
one, you're responsible for storing it, and Snowflake
basically has a metadata pointer that that
uses it. So that's why
you have this like sort of custom
configuration that you have to do on it.
Um, and then there's some other issues like
we've hit like auto refresh can sometimes stop
silently and so this is what I
mean, there's these little edges
that you gotta monitor and just make sure it works
in the integration that you have.
And so what we often have done with the deployment
is we actually just run an iceberg in parallel
with an existing system or we monitor
it for a week or two and we just make sure that it's working
and then we, we flip it over.
Um, and on the other side,
um,
so these are some of the iceberg learnings from the other
side. Um,
Uniform has its own constraints,
um, so, uh, the,
the client access is read only,
so if you wanna write to anything you have to go
through Delta. That's similar to
like a Snowflake manage table, but, uh,
but it's, it's a constraint. There as well.
More importantly though, Uniform didn't work with deletion
vectors, and it didn't support multi-table,
multi-statement transactions.
And if you've done anything with a really complicated
multi-statement transaction in snowflake,
you really feel that when it's not there,
and it meant that for some of our streaming
jobs,
their aggregates would not come together in a synchronized.
Way so we'd actually have like
oh the month over month streams
don't quite match the week over week streams
for like a couple of hours
and that's kind of a pain so they're
also to my knowledge working on these things as well
so the next version of Iceberg will solve that which
just makes it easier to bring Snowflake to
that data
and vice versa, which is really neat.
So I won't, I won't go into too much about like choosing
the format, but there are options for how
you can do it with like
you can do delta with Unity
catalog, you can choose native iceberg or you
can choose, uh, you can use uniform
to bring like native iceberg and delta tables
together. Um, but just the, the
takeaway here is that
apply curiosity because there's going to be edges
involved with these things
and there's sophisticated
integration between the metadata
management between engines
and that metadata management, it doesn't just
always plug in sometimes it. Doesn't work so
we've had to do like custom jobs that have run
for a temporary period of time
that just update metadata
uh for this uh and and actually
we've worked directly with with partners like Snowflake
and they've actually like enhanced the offering
and and then that we didn't have to do that anymore
which is really cool
um
so outcomes uh where do we land with
all this? I think you probably got the the gist already
but it's working pretty well for us
um so improved efficiency
um so the one of the big things is that.
Massively reduced copies, compute,
and EC2
for all of these shenanigans that we're doing
moving data around. So it's actually really
come down. We had a 70% reduction in our
EC2 usage from
the data brick side in terms of managing
metadata and everything, which is really great. So
it helped reduce our costs there.
We also got this, this dream
together of a single consistent
data layer and source of truth where we have applied
it. So that means uh
our internal tools like Opus
and externally facing ones like
or artist facing ones like WMG Pulse,
our ML feature store,
they're actually able to use the same
tables in an engine agnostic way
across these different offerings, and that's a
really big deal for us because.
We, because
we actually have a business where
a lot of business users are skeptical of the data,
right, and you probably, if you're,
if you're in a complex organization,
they're probably like, can I trust it? And so one
of the worst things for trust in data
is if you have two clocks, right? Like,
so, so it's not good when you have different
representations. So I, I view Iceberg
as a lever for helping with that
organizational problem, not just the technical one
of trust in data, because you can at least
get down to one clock.
And not have a 2 clock problem and once you're there,
you can start to characterize that data and
prove it's good or correct it or or show
how good it is,
and you don't have to do that multiple times
because anytime someone sees a different data source
they're gonna go and ask, wait a minute, which one's right? Is
this one right? And they probably have a bias
about it too and be like, I think this one's right.
So like a lot of the little the requests
I get from our business users are like, hey,
I saw this data anomaly and it doesn't make
sense. And so can you help us
figure it out? We have a thing that we need to launch
yesterday or something like that, right?
So it's really quite an interesting space to
be in where providing
this one
single representation of the data also
helps us to build trust with stakeholders
in terms of what that data is and it
simplifies our effort to characterize and
improve data quality as well.
Um,
the other thing is we saw shorter time to get
insights out, so we didn't have to set up
complex sophisticated systems
for serving up data to WMG Pulse,
um, and what that meant was we were able to actually
leverage, we brought Snowflake with all
of its data to the data products that are
powering Pulse,
so Snowflake is underneath a ton of that
data as well, and we didn't have to build
a ton of complex infrastructure to do it.
We were able to just icebergify it,
and it worked.
Um,
and so what that means is that we're actually
able to serve these things more efficiently.
We can deliver insights faster,
and By delivering insights faster, I mean we can spend
less time figuring out this infrastructure
and more time actually trying to build insights
like how's an artist doing? How can we help them. Perform
better where what recommendations can we make?
How do they think about the changing world of
technology around them? And we don't have to do this
like, oh, I gotta build a whole bunch of
infrastructure to make something just available
for me to start asking the question,
the important questions, right?
So,
um.
I think I'll come back to this
because this was like the big outcome that we had.
I think what we've managed to achieve, and we're
not, it's not 100% there yet in terms
of applying to all of our data yet, but for
where we're using this,
we actually have what I think is genuinely a
future ready open ecosystem
that has this
platform engine agnostic
data layer
that can be accessed from either
engines we want, even other external
ones. And that actually
allows us to basically make our
huge history of structured data
available for the next generation of things we're
doing like our machine learning and AI
because one of the things that structured AI work
has to do is it has to access all of the data that
you have across your organization.
So if you want to do that, you really want to have your data
in a platform agnostic way
because our future is going to be multiple
different, probably like 6 dozen
different engines potentially running different AI
workloads on things
and a lot of the business is spinning up work on
AI themselves as well and
and everyone's. Exploring this and so making
this data available and saying like this is where you get it
um is really really cool
really important
and so that supports team autonomy while helping
us to bring a standard that can
actually work for people right because it's
hard to push a standard that's not beneficial
but if everything is really accessible
pretty obvious benefit.
Um, OK,
I think that's it, that's all I had today.
Alright, yeah, I think that's a wrap.
Thanks everyone, thanks for coming out.